marvel studios is eternals the movie
that everybody's been talking about for
a crazy amount of time due to the scope
of it due to how big the movie is
actually going to be and the stars that
it cast
that's in the film that delivers i'll
just go ahead and say that right from
the get
it delivers
it it does the cast delivers there's so
much i love about this movie and there
are some things that i didn't like so
much which of course we're going to talk
about
but this is going to be my non-spoiler
review no spoilers here not going to
give anything away it doesn't come out
for another couple of weeks but
you should go see this movie when it
comes out one it's important it's very
very important to the mcu there are
things in this movie that you have to
know about they're big
and it's really really cool to see and
of course post credit scenes not really
going to say anything about them because
again no spoilers but they're important
one's really important to the mcu and
the other is important to the mcu as
well as the actual story that you see
inside of the eternals
this movie
to me
is beautiful
it's breathtakingly beautiful it's
something that
i didn't realize until i saw the movie
is something that i actually kind of
want in other films now i actually think
shang chi in the legend of the ten rings
was a beautiful movie as well i think
they did a very very incredible job on
that and when i say beautiful i am
talking about visually
visually it's stunning and it's massive
and the scenes that you see in this film
are breathtaking they're really really
cool but also the beauty comes and the
eternals with the characters right i
thought a lot of the beauty in chungchi
was the relationship between chongqi and
his mother i thought that was beautiful
and i think the same thing gets brought
into here in a larger scale because
there's so many different characters and
they really are a family
and it's really really cool to see now
when i say that it is not a typical
marvel movie it it's not now
that's not a bad thing because of course
it obviously still has aspects of a
marvel film because it is a marvel film
but
chloe the director just did closure did
such an amazing job
with this i think i think
a lot of people have been talking
about oh it seemed kind of slow well not
everything has to be non-stop
action-packed all the time
but don't get me wrong there's that in
there i will say this and i'll circle
back to this in just a bit some of the
fighting scenes are the best fighting
scenes that i i've really ever seen i
actually love how they were done i love
the cgi in some of them i love the
actual stunts that were pulled i love
all of the fighting like some of the
coolest fighting scenes you've ever seen
makari actually kind of stole the show
for me a little bit because of her
ability of speed the way she uses it and
the way they decided to like film it and
go with it i actually really really
loved and i wasn't expecting it
um
we've seen quicksilver seen the flash
you know we've seen a lot of we've seen
two quicksilvers we've seen a lot and
bakari sold the show for me
not overall but like when it comes to
the fights like her character is really
really cool
so let's just talk about some few key
details here the cast i mean you know
who's in the movie right i mean it's a
huge movie angelina jolie some hayek
richard madden camila gianni there's so
many people that are in this movie the
cast is insane and guess what surprise
they deliver i know that's not a
surprise to anybody because they know
what they're doing
even the
non-seasoned veteran actors that are in
it like leah mchugh
do a fantastic job like everybody does a
fantastic job playing their part and i
think the characters were were cast
very very well
i cared about the characters they're
you know it's a movie there is shocks
there are surprises
and you get invested in these characters
right you get invested in the
relationships that they have with each
other because they're a big family right
they're all eternals and they've lived
seven thousand years with each other
and what a great cast
to be a family and to show that so right
off the bat that's amazing i've already
talked a little bit about what i thought
about the visuals of the film
they're huge
you want to talk about like you know a
film having celestials in it they do a
fantastic job of introducing the
celestials and some people were asking i
know a lot of people have been asking
like oh are they just in like one part
no they you see a good amount of
celestials um you really really do
and you get a feel of how big
they are and how powerful they are like
really
it's really cool
now the powers of the eternals were
changed from the comics
um
slightly well slightly for some not so
slightly for some others
but
it's cool that they don't all have the
same powers i mean you've seen the
trailers by now you've seen that some of
them have different powers i've done
plenty of videos talking about their
powers in the mcu compared to the comics
the powers are shown very well
i like how they were shown and i like
how they're different because you know
some of them need each other more than
others some of them can't fight so well
whereas you have others like athena and
icarus who are the fighters right marvel
even came out with the thing that was
like these are the thinkers and these
are the fighters and it's really really
cool um again everyone compliments each
other in that perfect way to where it's
like yes together like we are the
eternals and together we can do it it's
very much a team up film with just one
team right
um
as far as the story is concerned i know
some people are gonna say it slow but
again that doesn't mean it's bad
i actually think chloe zhao did an
amazing job
at
showing
the past
present
uh all together in like a really
good way that doesn't get boring
i would sit there and i'd be like okay
this is
this is almost to the point where i'm
where i think if we go a little bit
longer it might get boring but then they
do something i'm like okay good now i'm
not bored and even though slow parts i
truly truly did enjoy and a lot of the
silver parts are the parts that i
actually found really touching or really
beautiful
so
no it's not action-packed explosions all
of the time but when that stuff does
happen it's insanely good it's done very
very well
so the slow parts are 100 necessary
usually my qualm is
if i see these slow parts and i feel
like
why
like why are you showing me this right
it's just
it's there's no point to it right it's
almost like filler this movie is over
two and a half hours long none of it is
filler which i truly appreciate i
appreciate that everything that you see
is very necessary
for the film and everything does
progress forward because that's another
qualm i have with some movies where it's
like you see this stuff and it's just
like
there's no point for it and it didn't
move the movie forward like why did i
see it that's that's a big thing with
movies to me
and that's not what i felt in the
eternals at all
like truly i
i like this movie a lot and i've
reflected on it a lot thinking about
these certain things thinking about the
pacing of the movie
thinking about the visuals and thinking
about the story overall the story
overall i think is really really good i
think it deals with some issues that if
the eternals were real would have to
deal with which i can very very much
appreciate
and i think a lot of people will feel
for all the care you know it's a family
okay you know
for those of you with big families or
even small families or just friends you
know it's like you don't always have the
same opinion right when you feel for
each people even the ones who have
opposite opinions you're like well i get
what you're saying here and i get what
you're saying here and like i get the
vision between one or two people and
everything it's like you you understand
that and you can appreciate both sides
which i appreciate because it's like oh
dang like i'm so emotionally connected
in this because
i feel for
more than one person right if there are
sides i feel for both sides
and i really appreciate that now
the fighting
the action um
yeah there are some slow parts but
there is some really really good action
scenes of course they fight the deviants
and the deviants i will say were kind of
a lot cooler than i thought they were
going to be i
i was
i was worried going in i was like okay
cgi bad guy cool cool right we've done
that before hopefully it's done well
sometimes it's done well sometimes it's
done not so well done very well done
very very well and there's a good little
you know twist on the deviants that i
like that they threw in there you know
that separates them from you know how it
is in the comics um
watching the eternals fight the deviants
kind of like outside of babylon
mesopotamia it's so cool like it's so
cool to see all the different internals
abilities and their attitudes towards
everything i mean it's just so cool it's
so cool and then
at the end no spoilers about obviously
about the ending but the way
they come together and fight and the way
their powers are showcased phenomenal
phenomenal some of the best action that
i've seen and i particularly
enjoyed it because it's not a huge cgi
army
i
i love avengers end game and i would say
this movie is big it's like on the level
of avengers in game
but if it had a cgi army like avengers
endgame it wouldn't work it worked
perfectly for avengers in game right
because thanos and his army and the
avengers and everybody it was glorious
this movie does not do that it's more
intimate which i can appreciate and i
truly did enjoy
um
some parts did run on a little bit long
right if we're gonna talk about some
things and i actually think this is
something that other people are going to
kind of have a problem with not myself
because i don't mind watching slow
movies if if it's necessary i again i
don't need action all of the time
um
i love the jokes i thought it was really
really funny i think some people
might not like the jokes but i
personally really really did love it um
jack camille nanjiani
is hilarious in this film they do a
really really good job
and then the other thing that i think
is you have kit harrington in this movie
and he's gonna be the black knight right
you know that he's dane whitman but you
don't see the black knight in this now
that's already been revealed it's not a
spoiler it's just something that i would
have really really loved to see
and unfortunately i think the other
thing i can't talk about
i the other thing that i didn't like i
can't talk about
um so a spoiler review will come after
the movies out and then we can really
dive into like all what i really really
loved and a couple of parts
that i i didn't necessarily
thought well this is stupid for the
movie i just kind of thought well maybe
that's
like moving forward that could have been
done differently because there could
have been a lot more potential if you
went this way instead of going this way
and that's really like the only thing is
i think they're i think they could have
went in a different direction and some
very very like two cases
um that could have set up some cool
things for the future
and i believe it's actually only two
cases that i
that i that i think could have went in a
different direction but the overall
direction of the movie was fantastic
the overall i think imagination of what
everybody pictured that came to life on
screen was fantastic as well um the
story is really really good
um
it's fascinating to see
these characters who
you know were there at the beginning of
the earth and it's fascinating to see
the celestials and their plan for the
universe because remember they're
they're gods right they're cosmic
entities they have plans and they get
revealed in this movie right you you get
a grasp on the marvel cinematic
universe and i emphasize universe put
emphasis on that because you know in the
marvel cinematic universe we're on earth
most of the time right with the
exception of like thor and
you know captain marvel um
with a few exceptions everything is
pretty much earthbound so guardians of
the galaxy
obviously
um this is like it gives you a very big
understanding of how
big the universe actually is
and how
marvel's about to go in there and
explore this universe so it's really
really
really really cool
overall
i thought about this a lot after i saw
it at the premiere i love the movie i do
it's not the greatest marvel film of all
time and i did like shanghi more
but shangchi to me is like top top top
tier marvel like if we if we don't put
in game and infinity war in which i
never do in like reviews it's it's top
two top two
eternals is probably
i don't know where to rank it but it's
in my top ten um
and i don't think that's gonna be that
way for a lot of people i think it's
gonna be that way for a lot but at the
same time not i think there is going to
be a little bit of a division on this
but only because there
i think there might be
a little bit of an expectations of
marvel movies to uphold a certain type
of uh not standard
but
do what the other marvels kind of did
what the other marvel movies kind of did
and this this isn't
that
this isn't a typical marvel movie which
is actually kind of why i liked it a lot
more of course i love marvel movies but
it's nice to get a change every now and
then and this is a deep movie and it is
a dense movie and some people don't want
that right some people want their marvel
movies just to be a bunch of cool things
and explosions and superheroes and i
totally get that because i love it too
but to me i do like this type of
filmmaking as well so i really love this
movie i think i'm gonna give it
an eight out of ten
i think originally i'd give it a seven
out of ten but i reflected on it a
little bit more
and i thought
no i actually did like some of this
stuff and i understand why they did it
and i do appreciate a lot of the movie
um so i give it eight out of ten and i
think if you watch it you'll appreciate
a lot of it and and truly to watch it on
screen is it's stunning it's stunning
and quite quite quite
enjoyable and definitely an experience
so definitely go see marvel's eternals
when it comes out because it's it's a
fantastic movie and it's a very very
important movie to the future of the mcu
let me know what you think about my
review in the comments down below how
excited are you to see eternals be sure
to let me know don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos for live updates you can follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof